it's lights out and away we go in a
world struggling with a climate
emergency the gas-guzzling cars of
Formula One have an image problem the
sport produces the equivalent to a
quarter of a million tons of carbon
dioxide on and off the track every
season but in an exclusive interview
with Sky News the f1 boss committed to
reducing carbon emissions to Net Zero by
2030 we think we can play a real
leadership role in terms of reducing
carbon emissions and ultimately
eliminating carbon emissions from the
combustion engine and I think that is
through both fuel technologies biofuels
potentially down the road things like
hydrogen fuels as well as energy
recapture there's another risk that in
effect you're supporting a redundant
technology that the internal combustion
engine the traditional petrol and diesel
car come 2030 will be phased out I think
the numbers something like you know a
billion cars are combustion engine cars
and to the degree we can be a platform
that shows what's possible in reducing
emissions and creating you know more
efficiency through those cheap
combustion engines we think is an
incredibly important part of the story
and we think is an incredibly important
part of the solution
eliminating emissions from the entire
sport is a huge challenge
less than 1% actually come from the
racecars themselves around 27% are
generated by business travel and hotels
and 26% by factories and operations but
by far the biggest proportion comes from
logistics 45% of the sports carbon
footprint comes from transporting cars
and equipment around the world
but it's the cars that grab the
headlines an environmental activists say
f1 should be far more ambitious I think
it's a real shame that they're not
putting the best frames that they have
into the genuinely new technologies that
we need in terms of electric vehicles
and for me that's a missed opportunity
I'm sure there are a lot of people
within f1 who would like to be going
down that pathway
Lewis Hamilton recently urged fans to go
vegan to reduce their greenhouse gas
emissions Formula One says the drivers
and teams support the new Zero cotton
target even though there may be a slight
drop in the car's performance but the
sport knows that in a greener future the
thirst for speed will have to be
balanced with the environment Thomas
More Sky News